So one of the funniest things that we've seen
since the election is this sort of Dr. Jekyll
and Mr. Hyde bipolar Fox News, that Fox News
on the one hand, has the people saying Biden
won and Trump's furious with them.
And Trump is, in fact, so furious with that
side of Fox News that he's been tweeting and
advocating for people to go watch Newsmax
and on instead of Fox News.
But at the same time, Donald Trump still has
a lot of friends at Fox News.
And if you look at the nighttime opinion programing,
Tucker Carlson, people like Lou Dobbs, I believe,
over on Fox Business during the day, Maria
Bartiromo, Judge Jeanine Pirro, certainly
Sean Hannity, they're still saying Trump won
this thing and Joe Biden stole it with fraud.
So it's just wacky because it is very bipolar
in nature.
Now, with all of this, it came to a head in
spectacular fashion when bomb throwing conspiracy
host Jesse Watters went up against Geraldo
Rivera in just a ridiculous assessment of
the Rudy Giuliani meltdown interview or meltdown
press conference where Rudy Giuliani's hair
dye was melting.
And Cydney Powell said that there was proof
from Venezuela and Cuba and George Soros,
they're all involved in the conspiracy.
That crazy press conference was so nuts that
even Trump supporter Geraldo Rivera, even
a friend of Trump, Geraldo Rivera, had to
say, listen, this these are conspiracies.
This is over, right?
This is done.
And Jesse Watters didn't like it.
And it just falls apart absolutely brilliantly.
We'll see what happens.
Come on, Jesse.
I mean, really, come on.
I know the Clinton Foundation, George Soros,
Hugo Chavez.
I'm probably the only person in this building
I've actually met Hugo Chavez that Hugo Chavez
anything will make the red light talk about
the sworn affidavit and an international conspiracy.
Why not Elvis?
You know, I didn't mention anything like when
I'm talking sort of your lawyer.
I love lawyer as a lawyer, acting president.
I wanted him to win this election.
What I saw with Rudy Giuliani, who I've known
for decades, was bizarre, was unfocused.
There was conspiracy theory, this and that.
You when you have evidence that you suggest
what's the lawsuit that that evidence attaches
to, what's the action?
You can't go to a court and say, that's fraud,
judge, prove it for me.
Or is the FBI to prove it for me?
They have not the pending lawsuits right now
in three different states that they're going
to drop Michigan.
They find hard to judge.
It's going to ruin giving false hope.
All Americans should want everybody to be
confident in the results of the election.
So if you don't pursue these fraud allegations,
half the country is going to feel like it
was crooked.
You don't want that.
And so Jesse Waters says if you don't pursue
the allegations, the country will believe
it was crooked.
Well, half the country already believes that.
And when the fraud allegations get thrown
out, they're not going to say, oh, the allegations
were thrown out.
I guess there was no fraud.
Of course not.
When courts throw out the fraud allegations,
these people instead say, well, the courts
are part of the conspiracy.
The courts are in on it, obviously.
And this is just like Sidney Powell said on
the Newsmax interview I played for you.
And she says there are thousands of people
involved in this conspiracy.
Why not judges as well?
So Jesse saying in order to make people confident
it wasn't crooked, we have to let this play
its way through the courts.
No, no.
The courts have become part of the conspiracy.
And Trump's defenders keep talking about the
existence of sworn affidavits.
Simply having sworn affidavits doesn't prove
anything.
Affidavits are a type of evidence.
Affidavits are a type of evidence, much like
witness testimony.
Sometimes witness testimony and affidavits
are admissible.
Sometimes they are not.
Sometimes they are credible.
The fact that there is an affidavit or 100
affidavits or 10000 affidavits, it means nothing
other than there is a witness willing to say
something.
That's all it means.
It might or might not be credible.
It might or may not be hearsay.
It may or may not be admissible.
Having affidavits doesn't mean more than that.
And when you start looking into some of these
affidavits that they have some list, they've
got lawsuits in Michigan listing towns from
Minnesota.
They have people signing affidavits who, when
asked what happened, can't put together even
one coherent sentence about what on earth
is it you are even alleging took place here.
And then you'll have, you know, Rudy and others
say they signed these affidavits under penalty
of perjury.
People testify in court under penalty of.
Perjury as well, testimony is often disregarded
as either unreliable or biased or dishonest,
you rarely see perjury charges.
Perjury is very hard to prove.
You very rarely see it.
It goes to proving that someone knowingly
lied versus just misspoke.
It's easier to simply call into question the
reliability of what they say and ignore it.
If you determine it's not trustworthy, then
to go charging people with perjury.
And it's the same thing with these sworn affidavit.
So listen, Heraldo is a total clowned.
He supported Trump.
He is Trump's friend.
He wanted Trump to win.
So Geraldo is not now our go to guy.
He's just sort of like, imagine a group of
drunk people at a party behaving insanely.
Someone is bound to be the first to sober
up.
It doesn't mean that they exercised good judgment
to begin with.
They're just the first guy to sober up and
say what the hell happened here?
And that's what is going on with Heraldo.
But he was just as much a part of this as
anybody else